et mais juste cette histoire de réunion
anti blanc comprenez que c'est ça peut
choquer les gens c'est encore une fois
il faut de revenir sur qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est pas des réunions on dirait
que notamment quand vous expliquer on
faisait des rassemblements qui seraient
autorisés que enfin interdit aux blancs
c'est faux et d'ailleurs le mot qu'on
utilise c'est pas des réunions interdit
aux blancs ça c'était les mots de sonia
mabrouk l'unef qu'est ce qu'elle fait
elle organise en fait plus ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des groupes de parole
des groupes de parole pour les femmes
pour les personnes qui sont victimes de
racisme et pour les personnes lgbt dans
l'organisation qui veulent témoigner de
ce qu'elles ont pu subir
donc en fait c'est simplement un temps
où il ya des personnes qui se réunissent
et qui vont discuter de ce qu'elles ont
pu dire c'est tout y'a pas de décisions
il n'y a pas même de discussion sur
comment on va s'organiser pour lutter
contre le racisme lutter contre le
sexisme et c est à la base d'où ça vient
bah ça vient du fait qu'en 2010 il ya
des femmes dans l'unef qui ont demandé à
avoir ses cadres là pour pouvoir
s'exprimer sur ce qu'elle subissait je
pense que beaucoup de gens ont entendu
parler du fait que bas pendant la vague
nitoo l'unef a pas été épargnée il ya
des agressions que sont le lieu est
justement ces réunions ont permis de
remonter ce genre de choses donc là on a
faim on fait simplement la même chose
sur la question du risque on avait pas
mal de mélanie luce vous convient non
pas du tout d'abord je voudrais d'abord
que dire je suis désolé du message que
vous avez reçue une à ce genre soit à
peu près 10 par jour vous savez comme ça
et je pense qu'au tour de ce plateau
tout le monde pourra témoigner de la
même serre lorsque vous êtes bienvenu
sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
non je vais je vais vous parler
gourinoise mans series
mais je vais vous parler directement la
gauche républicaine dont je me réclame
doit subir depuis des années une autre
gauche la gauche que vous incarnez dont
vous êtes la tête de gondole une gauche
délirante une gauche irresponsable
une gauche islamo-gauchiste racialiste
indigéniste bien et je vais vous le dire
très franchement j'en ai marre nouveau
délire si vous ne comprenez pas à l'unef
de participer au lynchage médiatique de
deux professeurs à grenoble ça peut
avoir des conséquences tragiques les
conséquences criminelles
si vous ne comprenez pas qu interdire
des réunions à des hommes ou interdire
des réunions à des blancs contrevient à
tous les principes de la république et
de la france en général il n'y a plus
qu'une solution c'est celle que je
voudrais que l'ami 6
ce soir la dissolution de votre syndic
15e n'est pas récente et moi je termine
c'est ce qu'a demandé avec succès
presque fusionner la démocratie la dgi
presque d'accord mais j'ai presque fini
votre syndicat n'a rien à faire des
intérêts étudiants et tout à faire avec
des intérêts idéologiques vous êtes un
syndicat idéologique votre idéologie et
mortifère votre idéologie et dangereuse
vous ne cessez de jour après jour et cet
épisode n'est que le dernier en date
d'une longue suite de dérives et de
dérapages dit vraiment je suis pour la
destruction de notre syndicat et il
repart sur des bases plus saines
voilà donc déjà premier élément de
réponse je comprends pas pourquoi vous
me dites que on s'intéresse pas aux
étudiants
concrètement où c'est pas moi qui ai
demandé de parler à parler de ça dans
cette interview la première chose dont
j'ai parlé c'est quoi c'est la précarité
j'étais là pour ça et au moment où on me
parle de trucs qui n'ont rien à voir on
ne parle pas de en plus vous me parlez
comme si voilà c'est pas comme si on
fait ce genre de réunion pour les jours
ces groupes de paroles c'est quoi ces
maximum deux fois par an pour que les
personnes s'expriment entre elles c'est
tout et quand vous dites qu'on se
soucierait pas des étudiants mais je
suis désolé monsieur le 16 mars qui
étaient dans la rue qui a organisé une
manifestation historique parce que il y
avait des étudiants dans la rue des
jeunes dans la rue alors que les
universités soient fermés mais je suis
désolé mais par contre le complotisme ça
aussi c'est un quelque chose qui
pourrait en appeler au lynchage de deux
professeurs n'a pas à dormir l'argent
les intérêts des extensions alors qua
non réalisés n'a pas il y aura sioniste
c'est prendre en mains c'est bon tu sais
les spectateurs cette histoire
de grenoble il ya quelques jours l'une
est donc votre syndicat était déjà au
coeur d'un scandale après que la section
locale de grenoble avait partagé sur les
réseaux sociaux
les noms de professeur de sciences po
grenoble accusé d'une prétendue
islamophobie une affaire qui avait
provoqué bien entendu un tollé ça c'est
vrai que c'était également un violon de
gauche
ça vous a pas suffi samuel pâtit vous
voulez que y ait droit au passeur de
cannes et vous pensez vraiment que
samuel petit c'est notre responsabilité
parce qu'on a rien à voir avec ça non
mais c'est le genre de propos qui font
d'énormes est arrivé des choses
tragiques à d'autres professeurs
accueillent encore une fois que je vais
répondre vous comptez juste continuer à
raconter des choses fausses à
l'interruption ou là dessus moi j'ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois que l'unef elle
n'était pas pour la chaîne publique de
qui que ce soit même quand il ya des
désaccords
même quand là on en enseignant en
l'occurrence qui a tenu des propos comme
je suis nazi de par mes gènes même quand
on dit ça va on n'affiche pas le nom des
personnes et c'est pour ça qu'on a à la
fois reconnu que c'était une erreur de
la part de la section locale d'avoir
publié je rappelle quand même que la
seule chose qui a été faite c'était des
photos du collage et c'était pas des
photos simplement de cette image là
c'était des photos qui rassemblait tout
le collage donc il y avait notamment un
collège qui dénoncé des agressions de
sciences po mais bon dans tous les cas
ça reste une erreur une erreur aussi
bien maladroite que dangereuse parce que
maladroite parce que bath a jamais été
l'objectif de lyncher que ce soir je
mets dangereux aussi parce que
effectivement c'est un risque
reconnaissons lui présenter nos excuses
aux enseignants et cette image a été
très rapidement supprimer une classe
grossir un peu le rôle de l'unef dans
cette histoire